I don't want to be political here but
let's just talk facts Barack Obama was
wildly popular in Germany wildly popular
they loved him didn't he give that
speech but it was before he was
president when he was gay like a million
people's yeah great a nice any
maintained his popularity people loved
him but he didn't get any of his
signature programs or policies through
and I mean that you look at TTIP which
was the economic signature program of
the Obama administration the Germans
killed it
they literally led the fight to kill it
Nordstrom too we said don't build it
they went ahead and built it ja Kapali
the Nazi prison guard living in New York
City for 12 years the US courts said get
him out of here he lied to us we want
him back in Germany the Germans wouldn't
take him the entire eight years of the
Obama administration they asked will you
take this Nazi prison guard back they
ignored him defense spending we asked in
very nice ways can you raise your
defense spending
you know we think that you should be a
better man a NATO member they largely
didn't do it and so all of those issues
were were solved under the Trump
administration so I've actually said to
Chancellor Merkel in to the foreign
minister and two others in Germany
you're gonna have to deal with some
tough tweets yeah you're gonna have to
deal with some pushing and some ribbing
because the only way that we can read
this is that the Donald Trump style has
worked
so Trump okay so let's just sort of
piecing this all together then now you
have this guy who you don't have to walk
that type road tightrope with we had 17
candidates in the in the primary and
Donald Trump really just suck out and so
I was really excited to work for him I
mean look this is a guy who who was very
clear in the in the campaign that that
he wanted to treat everybody the same he
really did and and so I liked working
for him because he was challenging us on
the Iraq war implementation and saying
you know I thought it was a disastrous
decision
he was critiquing Bush and McCain and
Romney's positions on the Iraq war in a
Republican primary mm-hmm now everybody
around me had said oh he's done but that
was all the Washington type people who
were playing by the rules and if you
took their rules he would have been done
but the primary is really about the
people outside of Washington and that's
where I felt like I was reading the
situation better than what they were
because my sphere wasn't what the
Washington crowd was was saying about
he's done and and he's not acting like a
Republican it was with the Republican
base or the people and how they were
responding to
yeah that's an obvious the Iraq war the
management didn't go well and so that
was an honest assessment of you know
some people say touching the third rail
of politics of saying the things you're
not supposed to say and I like that but
Rick I don't understand everybody says
if you listen to the mainstream media
that everyone in the world they don't
respect us anymore and they think he's a
buffoon and all of these things could
that possibly not be true I mean that's
what the New York Times is telling us
I'm really joking aside like what are
you seeing like as now as an ambassador
and when you go to all the NATO things
and all the places you go to and all the
meetings do you sense like that people
suddenly don't respect us they used to
respect us they don't or we're not the
Patsy anymore perhaps yeah like
what is the real temperature I think
what you're really asking is does his
style work or does it not work right
compared to Barack Obama style which is
much different I think we should be
honest and and say we got two different
styles absolutely
Washington rulemaking will tell you that
Trump style does not work because they
doesn't participate in what their rules
are but let's look at that let's look at
whether or not his style works because
I'll take this argument all day long I
don't want to be political here but
let's just talk facts Barack Obama was
wildly popular in Germany wildly popular
they loved him didn't he give that
speech but it was before he was
president when he was gay like a million
people crazy
any-any maintained his popularity people
loved him but he didn't get any of his
signature programs or policies through
and I mean that you look at TTIP which
was the economic signature program of
the Obama administration the Germans
killed it they literally led the fight
to kill it
Nordstrom - we said don't build it they
went ahead and built it
Jacques Attali the Nazi prison guard
living in New York City for 12 years the
US courts said get him out of here he
lied to us we want him back in Germany
the Germans wouldn't take him the entire
eight years of the Obama administration
they asked will you take this Nazi
prison guard back they ignored him
defense spending we asked some very nice
ways can you raise your defense spending
you know we think that you should be a
better man a NATO member they largely
didn't do it and so all of those issues
were were solved under the Trump
administration so I've actually said to
Chancellor Merkel in to the Foreign
Minister and to others in Germany you're
gonna have to deal with some tough
tweets yeah you're gonna have to deal
with some pushing and some ribbing
because the only way that we can read
this is that the Donald Trump style has
worked do you think they secretly liked
it but sort of publicly I don't mean
Germany specifically but generally that
countries and leaders they have to sort
of pretend that they don't like Trump
but as they see the u.s. sort of
reassert itself
and maybe even as he forces them to pay
a little bit more actually pay their
share that in a weird way they almost do
like it because it helps give them a
little bit of their sovereignty back or
worship to look for another at that's
100 percent for sure
I think the public's in Europe like to
have the ability to have their
sovereignty back they they love and
President Trump has said this to
Chancellor Merkel I don't blame you for
not paying your NATO bill right and find
cheap Russian gas and having a 69
billion dollar surplus over us and
having a surplus and fifty thousand
American troops protecting you I don't
blame you who wouldn't do that if you
were the Chancellor of Germany so but
then he says but now it stops here
because you're outsmarted all these
other presidents and now I have to stick
up for my people so if Trump is right
about all this stuff and now countries
are paying more and all of these witches
it he is totally right yeah so granted
so nearly so today's a bill right so
suddenly countries are starting to pay
their share is it just is it just what
you're saying that it was just the way
Washington always worked and that it or
is it just that we refused to use any
influence on countries like that we were
just it was just always easier to just
be like ah we'll pay for everything or
you know what I mean like I think it's
some of it is our own fault and and
you're getting that that's what I guess
that's what I'm asking that it was just
we kept bringing in people that just
were always like oh we're paying and why
wouldn't we pay yeah and we got to be
nice and now they're pushing back and we
want to be pro-european and and so let's
just have a dinner party and and you
know people have a lot of parties yeah
and sitting in European capitals and
really you know we spent we have all of
these people in European capitals
working at our embassies I look I think
our embassies should be mini commerce
sections you know I've got a whole bunch
of people at the Embassy who are super
smart and and very committed to the
United States and do great public
service but I have come to the
conclusion that having a whole team of
people watching the German political
system and reporting back to Washington
by writing cables about what's happening
in in the governor's race Minister
president's race in a state in German
all of that stuff super interesting
completely irrelevant in many ways we
can get that information off the
internet after it happens we don't need
reporting officers to do that what we do
need our economic specialists on LNG
liquid natural gas or economic
specialists on medical devices to help
us get us companies growing in Europe I
think that our embassies need to be
transformed less on the political side
less about the politics of the country
that we can get through the internet all
this was established before we had the
internet and now we need to turn these
these embassies into America first
economic models just like what other
countries do we're the only country in
the world that gets in trouble for
pushing ourself forward everybody's
doing it but we're the one that gets in
trouble for saying oh how dare you yeah
did you by any chance read that book
that I've got right there your Rome
Arizona the virtue of nationalism no
because his whole his whole idea of
reading we're done with Maurice though
oh there you go well there's plenty of
there's a couple good Douglas Murray
books over here but the basic premise of
the book is that strong nations that you
have to be a strong nation first so be
America first be Germany first be
whatever your country is first and
that's how you by being a strong nation
first then you can create some sort of
international community that makes sense
but that really were just doing it all
backward or we've been doing it
backwards for decades which is we put
ourselves down and the thinking that
we're achieving some higher goal or
something and then we're end it we end
up screwing over everybody
yeah I think that makes a lot of sense
in and you know sometimes you have to be
able to put forward in a in a pushy way
your position in order to get things
done and that doesn't mean that the
relationship is ruined but it just means
that this is a priority and so you're
gonna push it harder I think that's been
one of the problems that we've had is
just the this kind of status quo let's
all you know you're supposed to say what
you want and I'm supposed to say what I
want and then we we kind of cut the baby
in half and we go away and and go to
lunch to me that's not diplomacy I mean
we have to be able to push forward our
agenda by the way
I've never I've been in thousands of
diplomatic discussions thousands I've
never been in one where the other side
doesn't ask for something and we ask for
something in return
it happens all the time yeah this is
called diplomacy yeah what do you want
what do I want you know it's this whole
thing and the idea that you're asking
for something is not a quid pro quo
it's called diplomacy this is exactly
what we do is we show up to a meeting
and we give our agenda of what we'd like
you to do and what we need and then you
do that and we pick and choose and when
you make it a priority this is what I
would say on the jacket poly the the
Nazi prison guard thing when I showed up
in Germany and I made this a priority
and I said this return of the Nazi
prison guard I brought it up in my first
meeting with the Foreign Minister and
you know what the Foreign Minister said
to me after I bought it up I've never
heard of this case huh okay that's
incredible the State Department had told
me oh we've asked for 12 years it's it's
gonna go nowhere but you should bring it
up in my Senate confirmation I got a
written question will you make JA Kapali
the return of the Nazi prison guard will
you make it a priority I said yes
and I said I did it and then President
Trump said to me you should really get
that Nazi prison guard returned and I'm
like I'm on it I brought it up in every
meeting I made it a priority
I had to educate them they returned them
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell